just as wind energy is poised to become
a major energy source people are
beginning to report problems like huge
wind machines built too close to
people's houses there was definitely not
necessary to put some 300 or 400 or 700
meters away from people's homes Lada
Nielsen lives in southern Sweden in 1999
her small village became the site of one
of Sweden's new wind farms almost
immediately neighbors began to talk
about loud noise and a disturbing strobe
light effect as the turbine blades cut
through the morning and evening sunlight
the wind companies must absolutely if
they believe in their business be much
more careful I had because this opinion
is growing and they will they will have
an enemy there
[Music]
people are coming up with common-sense
solutions like putting smaller turbines
in residential areas and the huge
machines further from people of course
the easiest way to avoid the troubles
associated with any technology is to
need less of it
the single biggest change in our economy
over the past thirty years hasn't been
information technology hasn't been you
know mass production or whatever else
it's been the change in our energy use
Americans are nearly 40% more efficient
today than during the OPEC oil crisis of
the 1970s that event turned conservation
into good business but the u.s. still
uses more energy and creates more
pollution per person than any large
nation the US has learned to conserve
but other nations have learned to
conserve much more renewable
technologies like solar panels wind
turbines and fuel cells also offer
another benefit they can be built
installed and used locally but US
government support for renewable
technologies still lags far behind
subsidies for nuclear oil or coal
we did the heavy lifting but we're now
giving away the store by not just
keeping up those pretty modest levels of
investment for years supporters a
renewable power have fought to make
clean energy competitive now technology
is catching up with that dream and when
people begin to see economic and
environmental benefits public attitudes
shouldn't be too far behind
you